hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and calm and today we're going to
go over ace inhibitors and after you
done went to this YouTube video don't
forget to access the free quiz that will
test you on this medication so let's get
started
what are ace inhibitors well to help us
learn this medication we're going to use
the mnemonic nurse which is going to
tell us the name of the drug and that
tells us how this drug works on the body
what it's used for what is it treat our
responsibilities as the nurse side
effects we can expect from this
medication and education pieces we need
to provide for our patient so first
let's talk about the name the letters a
stands for
angiotensin converting enzyme so what
these drugs do is they inhibit this
enzyme from really doing its job so ACE
plays a huge role in our wrath system
the renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system
and what this system does is the whole
goal of it is to manage our blood
pressure especially when our blood
pressure is low so when the blood
pressure is low this system kicks in
what it wants to do is it wants to get
angiotensin ii in the body working
because angiotensin ii as we learn from
our short series is a major vaso
constrictor of our vessels so that's
going to increase our blood pressure
plus it triggers the release of
aldosterone which is going to help put
more sodium and water into our
circulation which is going to help
increase our blood volume and this
patient can get their blood pressure
back up so that is what a steps but if
we want to throw an ACE inhibitor it's
going to cause the opposite effect it's
going to lower the blood pressure now
one thing you want to remember to help
make things easier on you while you're
studying is to remember that ACE
inhibitors in with pril P R I L so when
you're looking at your patients
medication list trying to figure out
which one's an ACE inhibitor or you're
taking an exam look for prio and some
examples of an ACE inhibitor is like
captopril lisinopril
ramipril or bins Aprill so what ace
inhibitors do is they inhibit this wrath
system and again that stands for
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system and
if you can understand how this system
works it's a breeze learning ACE
inhibitors because ACE inhibitors do the
opposite and what this system is really
supposed to do so let's quickly talk
about this system so a patient's blood
pressure drops it's really low and the
kidneys sense this and they're like hey
we got to do something about this low
blood pressure we're not gonna get
enough blood supply and we're gonna die
so what they do is they release renin
into the circulation and when Renton is
present in the circulation this causes
angiotensinogen which is a protein
created and produced in the liver to
create angiotensin 1 now remember the
goal of this whole system is to get
angiotensin 2 on board because it's a
major vaso constrictor so in order to do
that we have to have a spread the
angiotensin converting enzyme so
whenever that is present it's going to
convert this angiotensin 1 into
angiotensin 2 when we have angiotensin 2
present in the body we're gonna get
major vasoconstriction of vessels
increasing systemic vascular resistance
increasing blood pressure and it's gonna
trigger the release of aldosterone which
is going to help increase our blood
volume now if we throw an ACE inhibitor
on what's it gonna do it's going to
prevent this ace from doing its job so
we're not going to get the conversion of
angiotensin 1 into angiotensin 2 so
we're going to lower our blood pressure
now let's talk a little bit more about
this angiotensin converting enzyme ace
in angiotensin 2 to help drive home some
points so you can really understand your
role as a nurse and those education
pieces there will be really no reason to
memorize it because it just makes sense
okay so angiotensin converting enzyme
when we're not inhibiting it what it
does as we've already established is
that it converts angiotensin 1 into
angiotensin 2 we get major
vasoconstriction we increase blood
pressure systemic vascular resistance
now another thing that it does when
we're not inhibiting it is that it
activates a substance called bradykinin
by breaking it down now let's talk about
Brady cotton Brady honey is a substance
that's an inflammatory substance that
really helps dilate the vessels when we
dilate vessels we decrease like systemic
vascular resistance
hence the blood pressure so whenever you
have the right system kicking in the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system
kicking in it doesn't need dilation so
it's very important that it inactivates
this substance because we don't need
dilation if our blood pressure is low
but if we're throwing on an ACE
inhibitor we can benefit from this Brady
Cotton's
actions of dilation so it will inhibit
these ACE inhibitors will inhibit this
inactivation of this Brady cotton so
we'll increase the amount of a Brady
cotton present which is going to dilate
vessels and help us decrease our blood
pressure even more which is great but
one thing I really wants you to remember
because of this Brady con and it's an
inflammatory substance some patients can
have a side effect of having a
persistent dry cough and literally it
drops some patients just crazy because
they're just hacking and coughing all
the time and sometimes patients have to
be switched to another medication
because it's so bad and I've had
patients who have had this so this does
happen with ACE inhibitors so remember
Brady Conan can lead to that persistent
annoying dry cough now let's talk a
little bit more about this angiotensin 2
well we've already established it's a
major vaso constrictor so when we
constrict our vessels was I do it
increases systemic vascular resistance
and our blood pressure now another thing
angiotensin 2 does when it's in the
is this going to trigger the release of
this aldosterone and aldosterone
influences the kidneys to keep sodium
and water and the whole reason for that
is it's gonna really help increase our
blood volume which will help increase
our pressure even more now while it's
keeping the sodium in the water the
kidneys are going to be excreting
potassium so if we throw an ACE
inhibitor on we're going to prevent
remember angiotensin 1 turning into
angiotensin 2 so that right here is not
going to happen so our ace comes it X's
it out so what's the effects going to be
whenever we give our patient an ACE
inhibitor well we don't have the
conversion of angiotensin one to
angiotensin 2 so our blood pressure and
systemic vascular resistance will drop
what is going to happen with this sodium
and water well instead of keeping it
like how we did over here we're going to
excrete the sodium in water which is
going to provide like a diuretic effect
for our patient now this is good for
patients for instance who are in fluid
overload due to heart failure so here in
a moment we're going to get in what this
drug is really useful in potassium over
here we were excreting it well with ACE
inhibitors because how it's working on
the kidneys you can actually keep too
much potassium so with many patients you
have to watch their potassium levels
because they're at risk for hyperkalemia
so remember that ACE inhibitors
hyperkalemia
so nursing considerations will have to
be looking at those potassium levels and
educating our patients on what foods to
watch out for so that we don't increase
those levels now let's talk about what
ACE inhibitors are used for well we've
established that ACE inhibitors help
lower the blood pressure because we're
preventing that angiotensin 1 to
angiotensin 2 so it's great for people
who have hypertension it will lower
their blood pressure another thing it's
used to treat is heart failure
specifically systolic dysfunction and
this is where that left ventricle can't
really empty or pump blood forward out
of it through the aorta into the body so
instead that blood can back up go into
the
and lead to heart failure fluid overload
so our ace inhibitors what they can do
is they can help decrease after load and
remember after load and we're talking
about the left ventricle is where is the
pressure that the ventricle must
overcome in order to get that semilunar
valve open so blood can leave it so if
we decrease that resistance that
pressure that that ventricle must
overcome
hence the systemic vascular resistance
it'll make it a lot easier for that
ventricle to pump blood forward
in addition ace inhibitors are gonna
help decrease our preload and preload is
the amount of that ventricle has
stretched at the end of its filling
phase with blood so at the end of
diastole
another thing that ACE inhibitors will
help treat is a patient who has suffered
a myocardial infarction an MI so when
their post mi and what ACE inhibitors
will do because it alters a lot of this
after load and preload it will help
limit the effects of damage that can
happen to the heart once a patient has
had a myocardial infarction now let's
talk about the responsibilities of the
nurse okay whenever a patient is on an
ACE inhibitor what are you gonna do well
of course you're going to monitor their
blood pressure and their pulse routinely
you want to look at that see where
they're running with our blood pressure
because with ACE inhibitors there's a
risk of hypotension where that systolic
is less than 90 and that increases even
more of your patients on diuretics where
they're urinating a lot they're losing
other fluid volume and that can decrease
pressure or if they're on other blood
pressure medicines because a lot of
cardiac patients are going to be on a
variety of medication so you definitely
want to watch their blood pressure in
addition you want to monitor some things
like their potassium level make sure
that they're not experiencing
hyperkalemia and we talked about the
reason for that a normal potassium is
three point five to five so you want
them within that rain
and if they if you get an EKG or they're
on bedside monitoring you can look at
their EKG and one sign in symptom of
hyperkalemia with their EKG is that they
have tall peaked t-waves also you want
to be looking at their renal function so
their bu in and creatinine because
remember this drug can alter how our
kidneys work we're messing with the
sodium and the water and the potassium
so making sure that they're within range
and normal be you in is about 5 to 20
normal creatinine is 0.6 to 1.2 and of
course looking at how they're urinating
what is their urinary output we want it
in an adult at least 30 CC's per hour
another thing to remember with ACE
inhibitors is that you want to watch out
for a condition called angioedema this
is where they're a swelling of the
dermis and the sub-q tissue so we have
really deep swelling it's not
superficial swelling like you to care
yeah this is deep down in there and that
can be life-threatening
so how your patient will present with
this is that they can get swelling on
their face their mouth or extremities
and it can affect the airway where
they're gonna have difficulty breathing
so you want to educate your patient
about that what are the signs and
symptoms of it it's rare but it can
happen to any patient it's most common
they have found in African American
patients and if it happens it's
dangerous and they need medical
treatment immediately and lastly with
our responsibilities you want to look at
how your patient is really tolerating
this medication because I mentioned that
persistent dry cough it will literally
drive some people crazy because they're
constantly just hacking and coughing but
because this medication is prescribed
with people who also have heart failure
as a nurse you want to look and make
sure is this the persistent dry cough
associated with this medication or is
this heart failure exacerbation where
they're going into fluid overload so
you'd want to determine the two and how
you would look at that is you would
listen the lung sounds what is our lung
sunlight are they wet where they you can
hear crackles are they having difficulty
breathing on exertion just getting up
from the chair to the bed they're really
winded they can't breathe and they're
having swelling and they're
shrim ADIZ where the retaining fluid so
make sure you look at that and assess
that and just don't write it off that
it's that dry hacking cough that you get
with ace inhibitors because it could be
that they are in heart failure
exacerbation they'll talk about the
side-effects of ACE inhibitors well this
medication can cause that persistent dry
hacking cough and that was related to
that Brady Kannan and this is usually
harmless so if your patient has that let
them know that another thing is that it
can cause dizziness because we're
changing dealing with the blood pressure
so tell the patient to change positions
slowly when they get up because they can
become dizzy and they might fall it can
also cause hypotension because it can
lower the blood pressure too much it can
increase potassium levels at
hyperkalemia and it can cause angioedema
that dangerous swelling of the deep
tissues and if they experience that they
need medical treatment fast now let's
wrap up this lecture and let's talk
about the education pieces for the
patient so since your patient is taking
an ACE inhibitor which alters blood
pressure it's really important you
educate your patient to check their
blood pressure and pulse regularly and
to record it and to bring those
recordings to their follow-up visits so
the physician can see if this medication
is doing what it's supposed to do also
you want to educate your patient to
avoid salt substitutes with potassium
and consuming foods that are rich in
potassium like potatoes bananas pork
oranges tomatoes spinach avocados
because we could increase the potassium
level even more because remember ace
inhibitors how they work on the kidneys
they will call us the kidneys to keep
potassium now this education piece is
really important if the patient is also
taking other types of medications that
keep potassium like those potassium
sparing diuretics like spironolactone so
the patients at double risks for high
potassium level so really drive that
point home to them another thing is if
they do have that dry cough and can't
tolerate it some patients can tolerate
it and it's just fine but a lot of
patients when they do get it they can't
tolerate it they need to speak with
their physician about it instead of just
stopping taking
medication because some patients like it
was driving me crazy I just quit taking
it you don't want to quit taking an ACE
inhibitor because it can lead to a
condition called rebound hypertension
and this is where the blood pressure is
rebounding it's just like super high and
it's really hard to treat and bring it
down also teacher patient the signs and
symptoms associated with angioedema can
really occur at any any time so let them
know what may happen and what they
should do and miss dose because we don't
want our patient to just abruptly quit
taking this we want them to take it
whenever they need to how it's scheduled
and even if they feel unwell they need
to take the medication because of the
rebound hypertension so they miss a dose
and and they remember that same day that
they're supposed to take it they can go
ahead and take the dose but let's say
they didn't remember until the next day
well they would skip that dose that they
miss but take that scheduled dose that
is due that day they would never want to
double doses because that could lead to
severe hypotension okay so that wraps up
this lecture over ACE inhibitors thank
you so much for watching don't forget to
take the free quiz and to subscribe to
our channel for more videos